heute pflanzen wird zusammen tomaten und
zwar in mischkultur weil tomaten ja jede
menge fiesel schädlingen und krankheiten
haben und da kann es richtig hilfreich
sein wenn man sie zusammen mit anderen
gemüsen in ein beet pflanzt in eine
kühle pflanzt ein hochbeet oder ein
gewächshaus so dass die anderen pflanzen
unsere tomaten ein bisschen vor den
krankheiten und schädlingen beschützen
also willkommen in unserer tomaten
kuppel wir gucken jetzt mal wer hier mit
wem ins bett geht
tomaten haben viele traumpartner es ist
also absolut kein muss dass die jetzt
eher monogam in ihrem bett leben
ihr könnt euch einfach so viele von den
mischkultur partnern wie ihr wollt
aussuchen und die unter eure tomaten mit
ins bett oder auch ins gewächs aus
pflanzen und der erste traum partner ist
der sellerie
das ist ganz praktisch weil alle
pflanzen die ich jetzt hier vorstelle
bleiben relativ kleinen tomaten sind ja
so mit die höchsten gemüse die man im
gemüsegarten hat und die anderen
pflanzen die haben zum food der tomaten
richtig gut platz und kennen da auf der
südseite natürlich damit sie nicht ganz
im schatten stehen super gut wachsen
ohne dass sie die tomaten großartig
stören und der sellerie der hilft den
tomaten sogar weil der blattläuse
vertreibt das ist also eine tolle
mischkultur probiert das auf jeden fall
mal aus wenn die seele liegt es ist auch
komplett egal ob ihr stangensellerie
oder knollensellerie nehmen trat mir
nochmal zwei sind alle kohlgemüse also
egal ob brokkoli blumenkohl weißkohl
rotkohl wilsing was auch immer ihr gerne
11 das ist komplett egal tomaten und
kohl passen einfach super gut zusammen
und was auch richtig toll ist dass die
tomaten ganz gut gegen die kuschelige
wirken normalerweise hat man es ja sehr
sehr sehr schwer kohl ohne schutznetz
anzubauen weil es einfach den kohl weiß
leben und die weiße fliege und noch ein
paar andere größe häftlinge gibt die
einem das gärtner leben ganz schön
vermiesen können aber die tomaten die
vertreiben eben ganz viele von den kohl
schädlingen und halten die von denen
fern
das funktioniert nicht zu 100 prozent
also ich würd sagen die male wo wir
tomaten und kohle mischkultur ohne netz
an gebaut haben war so wichtig dass es
geklappt hat oder auch nicht geklappt
hat ich kann meinen kohl im gewächshaus
zumindest ganz gerne schon früher so
dass
der sagen wir mal ab februar ungefähr
schon im gewächshaus steht und schon
richtig groß ist werden die tomaten dann
reinkommen weil die tomaten ja auch
relativ viel platz brauchen kohl ist
auch ein relativ großes gemüse und sonst
sind die sich oft ein bisschen im weg
aber jetzt zum beispiel ist unser pro
kohle gerade erntereif wo die tomaten
ins gewächshaus kommen und das ergänzt
sich super gut also wer immer noch
kleinere kukulies die sind dann
vielleicht in ein zwei monaten soweit
und dann brauchen die tomaten den platz
der erst komplett selber wenn sie
wirklich groß sind und bis dahin können
sie denn richtig gut mit einem cool
gewächs teilen also da auch immer ein
bisschen drauf achten generell wenn man
mischkultur plant wie groß werden die
pflanzen ist der genug platz wann ist
welches krise abgeerntet und dann so ein
bisschen puzzlen bisschen tetris spielen
damit dass am ende dann auch gut hinhaut
und hier ist unser dritter kuppel
partner das basilikum lassen bestimmt
schon viele von euch ausprobiert weil
tomaten unterlegung sind so die
klassische mischkultur passen ja auch
total gut zusammen also gerade wenn man
tomaten ernten wenn ja eigentlich immer
auch basilikum
ich habe jetzt hier einfach mal ein
supermarkt basilikum gekauft weil das
für diejenigen von euch die vielleicht
ein bisschen faul sind oder noch kein
basilikum im haus vorgezogen haben eine
super möglichkeit ist auch wie viele
unterschiedliche pflanzen hier drin sind
ist sicher 30 oder mehr pflänzchen in
einem topf geben man für zwei euro
kaufen kann
und normalerweise hat basilikum ihr
einen viel größeren pflanzabstand co
einzelne pflanze ist damit es richtig
guten ertrag ergibt und auch nicht
sofort stirbt die dinger sind ja nach
ein paar wochen oft stand hinüber und
was ich ganz gerne mache ist er sich den
top auspacken und dann in den eimer mit
wasser stelle für sagen sie mal ein zwei
stunden für das sich die erde gelöst und
die wurzeln ein bisschen besser
voneinander trennen lassen und dann
friere ich dir ganz vorsichtig
auseinander und pflanzt einfach die
supermarkt basilikum pflänzchen unter
die tomaten im gewächshaus im freiland
mache ich das lieber nicht weil ich
nicht weiß was das hierfür nur sorte ist
und wie freiland geeignet die ist aber
meine erfahrung nachwachsen dem
gewächshaus richtig richtig gut jetzt
kommen gleich zwei neue kuppel partner
dazu dass es einmal der knoblauch und
die zwiebel
sie verstehen sich auch super guten mit
den tomaten man muss ein bisschen
aufpassen wie tomaten ja einen sehr viel
höheren wasserbedarf haben als die
zwiebeln dass man dann zumindest so
gegen reifezeit der knoblauch und
zwiebel pflanzen vielleicht ein bisschen
weniger liest und die ja ein bisschen
mehr austrocknen lässt so dass die
zwiebeln am ende nicht verfaulen das ist
da ganz wichtig funktioniert bei uns
aber eigentlich sehr sehr gut wie
zwiebeln die wachsen hier zum beispiel
auch schon seit märz und jetzt plötzlich
die tomaten mit dazu und dann sind die
zwiebeln auch schon bald abgeerntet und
manche pflanzen liegt zum beispiel auch
unser nächster kumpel partner helfen den
tomaten auch super so schön gesund zu
bleiben weil zum beispiel die petersilie
ich habe jetzt hier auch eine supermarkt
in der serie damit ich euch noch mal
zeigen kann dass man sich da auch nicht
so viel stress machen muss also einfach
sofort mitnehmen
das kennt ihr auch vereint sind da könnt
ihr locker 4 1 trainierte der seelen
pflanzen aus einem topf machen und die
unter eure tomatenpflanzen und sie
werden dann alle genauso groß wie der
hier vielleicht will ich sogar sechs
draus machen wer schaut mal wie dich die
stehen das ist gar nicht gut reli und
die werden es euch auf jeden fall danken
wenn er die vereinzelt und so könnt ihr
aus einem töpfchen super viel rausholen
und wie gefällt der linie die wirkt eben
auch gegen gladbach so ich bin bei dir
total lecker aber blattläuse die
ergreifen dann eher die flucht wenn die
riechen und das ist natürlich super
praktisch wenn man seine pflanzen dann
auf die art und weise gesund halten kann
und noch eine leckere ernte obendrauf
bekommen noch vielfältiger ernten kann
und die beete einfach munter bepflanzen
aber natürlich sind die richtigen
pflegemaßnahmen ganz genau so wichtig
wenn es darum geht deine tomatenpflanzen
gesund zu erhalten also schaue auf
jedenfalls nächstes da drüben vorbei
weil ich dir da zeige welche aufgaben
regelmäßig anfallen damit deine
tomatenpflanzen sich pudelwohl bei dir
fühlen und falls du deine tomaten noch
nicht gepflanzt hast dann schaue auf
jeden fall da unten vorbei weil ich dir
da eine anleitung erstellt habe was du
beim tomatenpflanzen beachten solltest
dann gehe raus macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner wir sehen uns am samstag
wieder um 10 für ein neues video